what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special to offer and
I love to see it explode so that you can
help change the planet so to help you on
your journey today we're gonna look at
the seven types of investors for your
business and how to find them so one of
the most common questions I get asked
from entrepreneurs is how do i fund my
business where do I get investors from I
have big dreams I want to grow super
quick and I need money to do it how do I
find the people to help me what are they
looking for what's the process let me
know so today I'm gonna give you the
seven different kinds of investors and
how to find them for your business
[Music]
number one is banks banks are the ones
that people seem to think about right
away people think I need to go and get
money from a bank and need to get a loan
needs apply to get the money and to help
me grow my business banks are the least
friendly towards startup entrepreneurs
of all almost all the investment classes
banks don't want to help entrepreneurs
understand what the business that the
bank is in they want to they want to
give money to people who are gonna pay
them back and startups have the highest
failure rate of any kind of business
right if you're looking at different
classes so why do I want to give money
to a startup I don't banks don't want to
give money to start it's not what they
have in their marketing and their
promotions but banks don't want to give
money to startups most banks if you
don't have at least three years of
history of financials and of growth and
of making money then you need the
personal guarantee the loan and so then
it's really just depending on your
credit history if you have good credit
history you can get a loan if you don't
have credit history you can but really
you have to wait until you have to
usually three years of traction with a
business that's growing and making money
before they'll ever give you a loan and
so a lot of people think well I need the
money to get there once I get there I
don't need your money anymore and that's
always the catch-22 or usually get
rejected because your business just
hasn't been around long enough unless
you have good personal credit so banks
are definitely an option but it's
usually not the best option
for entrepreneurs number two is friends
and family it's also called blood money
here we're looking at up to around fifty
thousand dollars so if you need you know
from ten dollars to fifty thousand
dollars and you're looking for an
investor it's usually gonna come from
friends family kindergarten classmates
you know a friend of a friend and an
uncle and you know something like that
it's usually not your most immediate
connections but it's one or two or three
degrees away a friend of a friend of a
friend kind of thing and if it's fifty
thousand dollars or less that you need
it's usually an unsophisticated investor
it's not a big time investor because
it's just not worth it to them the
amount of work to understand your
business to help mentor and train you
it's just not worth it to them and so
that's where usually with more
unsophisticated people usually they look
for like they know you they like you
they trust you they want to see you be
successful you could play the guilt card
remember when I helped you move that
piano you know to that other apartment
that you had and I've been here for you
right like you're playing on
heartstrings which investors like
sophistic investors won't care as much
about but friends and family will care
more about and basically they they want
to see a return but it's more that they
like you they know you they want to see
you succeed they want to try to help out
whatever where they can the thing they
be careful about is do you want them to
be a part of your company or not like do
you want
aunt Jill to be in your business do you
want her helping manage it you want to
be taking her advice you know are they
just giving you money or are they gonna
play an active role is it gonna be a
problem when you get together at
Thanksgiving aunt Jill is there just
those kind of things to figure out if it
doesn't work out what happens with your
relationship with aunt Jill and the
family and all that stuff can go
sideways so you really have to be
careful about working with with friends
and family but it could also work out in
a positive sense but if it's under fifty
thousand dollars you're really looking
at friends and family relatives friends
and friends to get that funded
[Music]
when number three are angels angels are
angel investors they are usually
successful individuals who built the
business for themselves they're
entrepreneurs or they're successful
professional and they're looking to
invest money into a company to make some
more money a lot of times there's a
category gap between the entrepreneurs
the people who are sophisticated
investors the people who are used to
taking companies and ramping them up
quickly versus just people who have
money and there's a term in the industry
called DDI which is dentists and doctors
with disposable income a lot of times
these guys have a lot of money because
they're a dentist and they make a lot of
money in their practice and they as my
dentists explained are kind of bored in
their life and they like to live through
their investments right so they're
buying stocks and real estate and all
this other stuff and then take a portion
to invest in the startups because they
want a little excitement do you want to
be able to brag to their friends and
they want to see something exciting
happening because their own business is
kind of boring and traditional and so
that's a dangerous kind of investor to
look for anytime you're bringing
somebody on at that level you ideally
want somebody who can help you who can
bring value to you give you connections
open up doors to you not just give you
money so it's dumb money you don't want
dumb money you want smart money you want
people who care who've done this before
it's not their first rodeo and they can
open up doors and connections for you
and so it's really important and at the
start it can be it can be hard because
you need the money
right you need money to grow and scale
and build this thing up and you don't
want to wait but if you have a bad angel
investor it's hard to get rid of them
and can think it can hurt your future
potential rounds if you ever want to go
get venture capital in the next step
they look at who your angel investors
are and if it's a bunch of people with
no experience and they're just giving
you money it's really hard to get the
next round so you really want to be
careful who you're getting your money
from a great way to start is just
through connections lawyers accountants
bookkeepers those kinds of people talk
to your lawyer talk to any lawyer that
you can kind of make a connection with
through friends family ask them who
their lawyers are who their accountants
are because those guys also do legal
work and accounting work for bigger
players for angel investors most angels
are not they don't have a website
don't say I'm an angel investor because
then they get pitched constantly a lot
of the angel investment deals happen
through word-of-mouth and networking and
so talking to lawyers and accountants
are a great way to be able to do that so
I try to make a list of 30 different
lawyers that I can go and meet in 30
different counts I can go and meet
through introductions through friends
and family and tell them what your idea
is and then now it's on their way there
and they're thinking about it for angel
investors in general they want to see
that they're making a return right they
want to be able to get out in six to
eight years so there's a path to exit
and get their money back and they want
to be making around twenty five to
thirty percent per year that's what kind
of happened at the beginning you'd
probably lose money at the beginning but
net like when you end up selling they've
made a twenty five to thirty percent
annual return on their deal so that's
not possible in every industry right
like if you're at a slow paced industry
if you're in a retail store like that's
gonna be hard to get those kinds of
returns so may not be a good fit for you
to be going after angel investors but in
general that's what they look for and
the range is between fifty thousand and
two hundred fifty thousand on the fifty
thousand again you look at friends and
family over two hundred fifty thousand
you're looking at more of a
institutional investor we look at at
venture capital other kinds it's hard
for a single person to write you know a
million dollar check it's possible but
most angels playing a smaller arena and
so that's kind of the range that you're
looking for and how to get introduced to
them all right way number four is
venture capital this is the Big Daddy
these are the people with tons of money
they raise funds of hundreds of millions
of dollars and try to invest it into
high-growth companies to see major
returns angels starred in the 250 range
they don't really want to be there they
want to be in the millions range because
again the amount of work that's required
and doing a deal is pretty much the same
if a VC is putting five million dollars
into a company the amount of work to
research and do the due diligence is
pretty much the same if not less then
doing the work on a 250 thousand dollar
deal because by the time you've hit that
mark you've had some success you have
more traction then you're more of a
known quantity where it's a lot of work
to invest in to understand a newer
company and so they don't really want to
play in that low range but they're
hoping that if they give you 250 K
then you only come back for the next
round of a million in the next round a
five million to continue to grow venture
capitalists are also looking for 30
percent 25 to 30 percent annual return
and they want to be out shorter so they
want to be out in four to five years
typically they want to see that there's
a path to exit so that you're gonna get
acquired somebody's gonna buy you or
you're gonna go i pou so you're gonna go
to the stock market not that many
companies make it to the stock market
so typically they want to look for
acquisition so as part of your plan you
want to show who's gonna buy you but
there's an appetite that there's some
big company your multiple big companies
that will potentially want to buy you up
as you build and scale your business and
so understanding that is going to be
super important whenever you go and make
a pitch and again venture capitalists
now these guys do have websites you can
cold pitch you can cold email I was on
the other side of that I was receiving
the the cold pictures and emails from
entrepreneurs 99% of people get rejected
so your better path in is again through
a connection through a lawyer through
accountant again those are great
potential paths for you through your
angel investor that you made a smart
decision with they get the right one to
help bump you up and again remember for
any investor they want to look at use of
proceeds that's how you're gonna be
spending the money they want to see that
you're spending it on smart things so
you're paying yourself a salary but it's
not an insane salary right like you're
not paying yourself 100k to start this
business they want to see that
everything's going into the company
they're not interested in paying you a
huge salary they're not interested in
buying out another investor there are a
lot of times where somebody would come
to us and say we want to you know raise
money we need we need half a million
dollars and half of its gonna be used to
buy Oh at our first angel investor not
interested they don't want to buy on
another investor right they want to see
the monies being used to grow the
business and that your big payday is not
coming from your salary it's gonna be
when you build this company and
eventually sell it like your investment
is in the shares of owning that business
and then being acquired much more than
how much you're getting is paid so you
want to make sure keeping your your
salary expectations really in check
getting paid like less an industry
standard because your heart and soul
blood sweat and tears are going into
building this business
[Music]
we're number five is through customers
and this is a great path to do it where
you're not giving up any equity in your
business and this is where you are pre
selling your products your services
before you even launch it and so this is
where Kickstarter comes in and all of
those kind of companies where you are
marketing a product maybe you build a
prototype you make a video of it you
show off what it can do and before ever
going into production you're getting
orders in sales this is a fantastic way
to do it because it allows you to test
something right before ordering 10,000
of whatever product you're going to make
you make one you show that it works and
then you create a campaign to market and
promote it and if it takes off then you
have the funds to be able to go and do
it you don't need to go out and raise
capital from anybody and you don't lose
a chunk of your company and you're not
saddled with a ton of debt and if it
doesn't work out then you don't make the
product and all you're out is that one
prototype which cost you some money and
probably tons of time and effort and
labor but it wasn't this huge gigantic
expense and so if you can do it it's a
fantastic way to get the funding for
your business and also less of a dog and
pony show where typically like to raise
money from venture capital VC's angels
even friends and family can take a long
time and it takes away from you actually
building your business your spending
it's almost a full-time job pitching to
a venture capitalist which is time
you're not spending on building your
company and so if you can get those
pre-orders especially at the beginning
and show that there's interest like if
you have interest you have sales coming
in it's way easier to then get expansion
capital from friends or family from
angels from venture capitalists to
really build it to the next step up but
I definitely encourage you to explore
getting customers to fund it because
you're not risking anything besides a
little bit of time and you're not giving
up a huge chunk of your company
[Music]
we number six is to the government
governments depending on where you live
will have various different programs
they have at a city level at a state or
province level and at a national level
lots of different programs where you can
either get a grant which means they're
giving you money you don't have to pay
it back or they give you a loan where
they're giving you money but you have to
pay it back with interest and at various
rates a lot of times the government
programs are for specific kinds of
entrepreneur's so if you are an
immigrant entrepreneur you can qualify
if you're a woman entrepreneur you can
qualify if you're a young entrepreneur
you can qualify you're a tech
entrepreneur you can qualify and so more
than anything else the government really
cares about the background of where
you're from where for most other
investors angels VCS friends and family
they don't care if you're a woman or man
or Hispanic or you know they don't care
they don't care about that they kiss a
good idea you know do I believe in this
is this gonna make money it does have a
lot of opportunity where the
government's they care a lot more they
have lots of funds designed specifically
for different purposes and so we have to
figure out kind of where you fit in the
thing with government that is really
frustrated is that takes a long time and
so it's a lot of work to find the right
program the funds typically aren't huge
but I guess you know every little bit
can help it's just you may have to wait
months and months and months to first
get an approval just to get a yes
you may not even get a yes because you
apply and lots of people are applying
and you know it's a competition and then
even once you get a yes you have to wait
for that money to come in and by that
time a company may be dead right like we
need the money now you know
entrepreneurs are you know we don't have
patients who wanted to go let's go or
driving forward I want to wait months
for anything and so that's the biggest
drawback and deal with governments you
know the chance of you getting it and
then being able to wait for them to give
you a yes and all the paperwork and then
being wait to actually get the money one
other thing is just making sure - in the
program that the how you use the money
is also specific to a lot of different
government programs so like it can only
be used to buy product they can only be
used for R&D can only be used to hire
people sometimes the use cases is super
specific and then also sometimes the
programs prevent you from doing
something
that may be outside the interests of the
government so in Canada we have programs
that you can get funding for your
research and development but it has to
stay in Canada so you can't sell your
company to a us-based company four or
five years after you've gotten that
money which could really hurt you like
maybe your goal is to sell in three
years and I can't sell because I made
this deal with the government could be
an issue or might be within your state
like everything has to stay within the
state which could paint I you from be
able to sell your company or expand
elsewhere so just pay attention to the
fine details because there's going to be
a lot of them when dealing with the
government and the number seven ways to
suppliers a lot of times the suppliers
that you have to buy stuff from will be
potential investors for your business
one in either giving you product giving
you supplies like whatever they're
selling you if they're you want t-shirts
and they make t-shirts they may give you
the t-shirts right in in good faith or
like as owning a piece of your company
and so that's how it gets started or
just maybe on a discounted basis like
they believe on your plan they're not
taking a piece of your company they see
your vision of where you want to go they
give you the first run ad a really this
kind of price to help you get started
and then they're hoping to buy your
future business as you get going as an
entrepreneur at the beginning you don't
have a lot of money you don't allow the
resources so you have to be really
resourceful all right you got to be
really creative and one of the ways to
do that is through your suppliers so
look at every deal that you're making
with your suppliers try to find the best
deal possible try to get creative like
it might be you helping them with their
marketing or their website which may be
outside of the realm of what you're
selling but because you're doing that
they're gonna exchange product with you
to help you get to where you want to go
there may be some of that contra stuff
at the beginning to get started or
looking for any other way that you might
be able to get the product for free or
at a discounted price or potentially
have them invest in your business
because it can provide a lot more value
in the long term to get those product in
and help you get your business start so
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Bhim Singh asked
me to those are my seven tips my seven
ways and on the different kinds of
investors and how to find them I'd love
to know what do you guys think what was
most applicable or interesting for you
you can apply immediately to your
business did I miss an eight nine ten
you want to add to the list share it
down the comments below if you want to
vote on the next seven ways video that I
make there's a link in the description
go check it out go have your say cast
your vote and I might make it in a
future edition I also want to give a
quick charta to Kelley Quentin Kelley
thank you so much for picking up ten
copies of my book your one word and
giving it to your friends as gifts I
really really really appreciate it thank
you for all the support the YouTube
video everything means a lot to me and
I'm so glad that you enjoyed the read
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hoping continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon